All right guys, so this is going to be the last lecture of this course update
There will be plenty of course updates in the future
Um, I will also be teaching you guys the ICT 2323 mentorship when it's out
I'm gonna watch all of that content and I'm gonna upload it here
Like the important and like the things that actually matter and I'll it will skip all the talking and you don't have to be watching like
The long videos that I see these are gonna put out
but in this last final lecture, we're going to learn about Asian
Session strategy version 2.0
so
You want to use
FX and Asian session rage just as the old one, right?
so
what you want to look for is
Asian session, right? So simply you will you're gonna have Asian session like this and
Bill look for P.O.I.s below the Asian low and above the Asian high
So this does not require daily bias or market structure or whatever
so let's assume that
Whoops, that was terrible
Okay, so let's assume you have a POI right here, which could be an autoblock
okay, and
Once the Asian session is over which is going to be I believe
to
Am New York time
Right and the indicator is going to show you when the session is over so after that
When the session is over you want to see price go to that POI
So essentially you're looking at 15 minute first 15 minute, right? You mark at the PI or POI on 15 minute
And when the price reaches your POI you drop down to one minute time frame look for market structure shift
Take your entry from family gap break a block BPR family gap whatever we want to use and
Kaboom
It's that simple guys and similarly
Let me remove this and this if you have
Wow, terrible again
Okay, so
Wait a minute you have an autoblock here right on the 15 minute time frame make sure it's the first candle of the
Fair Valley gap we're gonna use that type of autoblock in this strategy, okay
And not like the ones like the way we use an autoflow
so simply once the Asian is over you wait for price to just drop down into your POI and
Drop down then you want to drop down to one minute look for market structure shift take your entry and boom
Very simple, okay
And unlike the Asian session
version 1.0 you can look for entry
Or you know price and come into your POI during the London session as well
Okay, so in the old strategy we had to look for shift in market structure during the lunch hour, okay?
but this
Version 2 can work in the London session as well the starting hours of London session
Okay, the starting hours of London session price comes into your POI you get marks to shift with displacement entry and boom
So I'm gonna give you guys a couple of examples